[Music]
as we all know being part of an
organization especially a large one
we're typically working with many
different people to deliver software to
customers and the process of doing so
isn't just a matter of writing and
shipping the code there's a lot of email
threads meetings documentation and
generally planning and design that goes
into it all so the idea with this demo
is showing a full Journey using powerful
tools spanning not just cloud but also
workspace search Bard and more to cover
the endtoend software life cycle so the
order we'll take is that of a typical
software depth cycle design Code test
deploy operate and we'll finish off with
analyze and this demo is meant to show
an example of how one developer me
working in a big business can use
different Google Cloud Tools around AI
assistance to ship a new feature the
scenario here is symbol Superstore a
grocery store web app that's running
completely on Google cloud and I'm a
backend developer working in typescript
on the inventory API which serves up the
products that are stored in a database
so my job is to implement a new feature
get new products which will serve up new
products on a new arrivals page in the
web app so first I need to write an
email to my teammate so I'll use do at a
and Gmail to ask them if tomorrow
morning is good to start working on this
new feature together duet AI will take
my prompt and write out an email for me
and this is a simple email but the more
context I give the better an email duet
AI can write for me so the next morning
I get together with this teammate and we
start brainstorming the implementation
of this new products page in a messy
whiteboard session and after the meeting
I jump into the architecture diagram
tool and use it to clean up that messy
whiteboard image into something easier
to read that I can share with my team
and I can save it as an image right here
in the tool now I want to make sure that
this architecture doesn't have any
glaring issues and consider what other
questions I should be asking so I'll use
Google Lens to upload the image into
Bard and I'll give some context on the
project and ask if there are any risks
with the architecture now Bard can read
the image and understand what I'm trying
to do with the web app and provide some
helpful information and in this case
it's calling out some risks and
questions around firestore how will I
handle the new products pagination error
handling Etc these are good questions to
think about so I'll export this
conversation into docs and have this be
the start of my design doc for this
project and once I have my doc started I
can use the do it AI help me write
feature in docs to ask for help creating
an outline for the design doc that that
I can then just populate with what I
need versus having to spend the time
outlining a dock when I have these
firestore risks to think about so I'll
send the design doc over to my team for
review and I'm updated that the ux team
has been working in figma on a front end
mockup for the new products page so uh
let's move to coding of the back end I
open up Cloud workstations as my
development environment and start in apy
I prompt do at AI at the top of the
screen to autogenerate an open API spec
for the new rest API
endpoint then I use an open API code
generator to autocreate typescript stub
code from that spec which is a great
starting point for my
code then back in workstations I'll
start to implement the business logic so
using doet ai's Code generation I can
prompt it right here in the code asking
for the firestore query that I want
which is to get new products that are in
stock do it AI will actually suggest
code for me and once I look it over I
can press tab if I want to accept the
code suggestions do it AI is trained on
Google Cloud documentation and client
libraries and it can suggest code based
on the contents of my open code file so
it can help me write code using the
firor node.js client while pulling in my
existing database fields and so now I
can start testing my code locally and
iterating as
[Music]
needed oh okay so I run into an error
coming from fire store and it's telling
me I can't have multiple inequality
filters but I'm not sure what that means
so I'll do what we all do and I'll
Google it and the generative results in
search will actually surface relevant
information from Pages like stack
overflow with links so that I can learn
more saving me a bunch of time
so with this information I can go back
to my code and fix the error and now I
should have a working Json list of new
products nice so with my error fixed I
can jump into testing using doet AI
again I can prompt it to write an
Express test using just or super test to
test the API endpoint and verify that
I'm seeing the response codes I want and
the right list of
products
and I can start running my tests through
Cloud
workstations and I should start seeing
the tests passing
here
great so once I get to a point where my
code is ready and my tests have passed
I'm ready to put out a pull request to
get this feature approved merged and
into the production pipeline which means
it's time to deploy so now I have a
running backend API in Google Cloud run
and a new API endpoint deployed so so
I'll check out the URL quickly to see
the production front end and I can see
that the new feature is working serving
up the list of brand new products with
the awesome design that the ux team put
together so now I've shipped my new
feature with the help of duet so what
now well the software development life
cycle doesn't end here so let's say I
need to be on call for this inventory
API the first thing I want to find are
the service logs especially in case of
an error so I open up do AI chat in the
Google Cloud console and ask it how to
the cloud run logs for the inventory API
and it gives me the steps I need to go
ahead and do that so I'm taking those
steps selecting the cloud run revision
resource and then finding the correct
log name to see the activity and I can
go ahead and run the
query and I'm seeing some of the logs
have errors so I'll take a sec to dig
into those a little bit and I can save
queries or modify them and it's actually
really nice to have the chat here
because I can reference it as I complete
those steps
steps so finally I can see that the logs
and everything seems to be running well
next I can work with the SRE team to
create some service level objectives for
the inventory service in Cloud
monitoring metrics Explorer so using to
AI help me modify feature I can create
complex queries on my service he in this
case asking to show for each Zone and
I'm definitely not a promql expert so
this feature saves me a lot of time that
I'd otherwise spend looking at a page
like this trying to find the right
syntax and instead I can learn while
getting the help from duet Ai and of
course we can't forget about security so
in security Command Center I can browse
vulnerabilities and findings and do it
AI actually generates summaries of the
findings so that I can easily understand
what specific issues there are with my
project and with this information I can
go ahead and fix the issue myself or I
can work with the security team to help
remediate so so a few weeks go by and
the product lead is asking for a few
slides for an upcoming executive update
so I get together with an analyst on my
team and the big question is of course
what is the impact of creating this new
product showcase did this leave to
improv sales or other helpful business
insights so in Google Sheets we're going
to ask do at AI to create a plan table
to help us analyze the sales impact so
here we have a table which we can fill
in with our own sales Targets later
on then we can go take a look at the
data in query again here we can prompt
duet AI right in the editor with the
pound sign and use the sequel completion
feature so that duet can help us finish
this query and we want the sales from
the sales rollup table on the weeks
before and after the new products page
was shipped so we can run the query and
see the results and for someone who's
less familiar with SQL this is very
helpful to speed up writing some valid
SQL queries and I can even take this one
step further for example if the analyst
wrote a complex SQL query and I want to
better understand it I can highlight the
SQL query and rightclick or use the tool
tip and have do at ai's SQL explanation
feature tell me what that query is
doing and next in spanner where I have
the raw transaction data I can use
similarly powerful SQL completion
features with duet AI as I dive deeper
into that raw
data finally my teammate and I have
collected a bunch of data to add to the
executive presentation slides and as we
build out the deck we can use duet AI in
Google slides to generate supporting
images in this case of happy Shoppers
that we can insert directly into our
deck to help demonstrate the impact of
this new
feature okay that was a lot to recap I
used Google's AI assistance features
from do at AI in workspace and Google
Cloud to B and search throughout the
software development life cycle to bring
an idea to life generative AI tools
helped me collect collaborate debug when
I got stuck and automate tasks to free
up my mind and time to help tackle some
harder stuff this only scratches the
surface of what duet AI can do hopefully
this inspires some ideas on different
features that you can explore for your
own use cases make sure to check out the
links in the description to get Hands-On
with duet AI by trying the learning
[Music]
path